autre chose d'abord un projet de loi
parce qu'on a besoin d'un projet de loi
pour éviter le référendum et pour que ça
puisse être adopté en congrès ce qui est
la meilleure voie on n'a pas besoin d'un
référendum pour un projet qui est
tellement majoritaire dans la société
bon deuxièmement un projet de loi
spécifique qui ne mélange pas toutes ces
questions qui est une qui est une prise
en otage du droit à l'IVG et enfin et
c'est ce à quoi nous serons très
attentifs une formulation qui reste à
trouver puisque l'assemblée Sénat en
voûtait des textes différents une
formulation qui soit réellement
protectrice c'est à dire une formulation
qui permette que si demain il y a une
loi qui veut revenir sur la qui cette
loi puisse être déclarée
anticonstitutionnel